and I didn't even know this you would
know this he was on the album Fisher's
album hoist it all happened across the
street from where I live from right now
he lived you lived across the street
we'll give you a dress but you lived
across the street in the house
supposedly your house groups lived in
yes and you play Trombone I lived next
to Paul Fox who produced among others to
look late great Paul Fox REM and Bjork
and Jacob Dillon and he was he was
wonderful
and the guys from
fish who he also produced obviously came
to his house and hung out and the
mailbox at that house across the street
from you used to be my mailbox was a cow
you ever seen those cows and it was
dented because so many people had hit it
as I'm sure this whole drive this whole
yeah it happens a lot it's sort of the
Cal version of that of the largemouth
bass mailbox which you see out in the
country right yeah and this was dented
to and so it was a landmark because
that's when you knew when we got to my
house or to Paul's house
so
they knew I played trombone because they
watched Star Trek and they were big fans
of the show and all that stuff Trey
Anastasia's there yes from fish and John
Fishman who I still know and they are
there with you they're there with me and
they ask Paul to ask me to play Trombone
on their album they're working on on
Saturday in a studio out in did they
know you were good they didn't that's
the story
so I'm invited out and I'm so psyched as
you can well imagine
I get in the studio they put the chart
up on the music stand it is beyond my
capability because I am only good or was
at that point only good now I really
have no lip at all but the chart was too
high it was too fast it was it was
completely yeah and I attempted it
so I played what I thought you know and
he said okay let's start again and we
and it was we became clear really fast
to me but they were being very patient
the engineer was being patient we try
and try it became very clear that it was
not it was not going to work but
so they ended up higher in the trombone
player from Tower of Power who was a
monster and but but the outtakes of my
attempts to play the charts on whatever
song it was I was meant to play on work
saved and became this 29 second cut on
hoist called
Riker's mailbox is the name of the song
obviously
it felt Riker he played
Riker or next Generation Boom come on it
was my mailbox it was my outtakes and
it's and and Paul God bless him gave me
a cold record I got a gold I got a hoist
gold record
on my wall framed God I used to I was I
was listening are you a fish guy I was
fish in college yeah before any of my
friends I can't spare a moment on the
dog fixed boy I won't lend another hand
to the warm girl of Hanoi
don't deplete my oxygen for the guy
who's turning blue but ask me and I'll
do anything for you remember that one
beautiful oh well let's go out to dinner
and see a movie that's the one I
remember oh yes